so we're here at e3 2015 speaking with
Adam boys I'm Justin hey Walt Sony had
an amazing press conference yesterday
how do you guys feel where you guys
pumped what was the crowd reaction like
how do you feel about so first of all
thank you that's awesome
um no we I feel really great I mean it's
always time it's kind of like a big
sporting event where you you prepare all
year long to put on a good show and I
think we go into it sort of humble heads
down just trying to put on you know try
to hopefully excite the fans and coming
out of that the reaction was super
positive so it's like I think we brought
a lot of things that people have been
looking for for many many years and I've
seen a lot of the tweets sort of after
the fact when he seems like a lot of
people are happy so yeah I'm very proud
of that what he was able to put up as a
show and I heard that one of the mantras
that you guys had was no leaks
was that true were you trying to keep
this stuff under wraps and how long did
you have to sit on things like last
night well yeah I mean that stuff I mean
obviously sure the worldwide studios
team they've been working on that game
for a long time and whenever people are
like oh it's canceled and then like when
Scott Brody correct um actually it's not
so what's happening it's very important
to us obviously like the integrity to me
there's so few surprises like these days
at the age of social media and stuff
like that that it's very hard the
meetings with Yu Suzuki when I flew over
to Japan you know we had to have them in
secrecy and we've been meeting at a lot
of conferences but we've done it off off
the strip and sort of secret dark Dungy
hotel rooms and stuff like that but
because it's really important to us I
mean you want to surprise people cuz if
you just showed up and show them much
stuff they were expecting it's not that
exciting so yeah there was it there is a
very very big focus on trying not to get
anything out there
and of course you Suzuki coming out that
Shenmue 3 Shenmue is just a beloved
franchise and three being announced on
the surface ages is amazing yeah I think
a lot of people are surprised that it's
not a Sony project though yeah so so
what why didn't you guys just say here's
your two million dollar here's the thing
right Shenmue Shenmue is like a religion
right and people around the world
it's very coveted but at the same time
when things are coveted sort of like
from an emotional perspective it's
sometimes hard to justify from a
commercial perspective so like we could
have spent you know a year sort of
getting consensus and trying to get the
funds internally and convincing other
people into the P&L and start
development then the game is announced
four years later or we could say hey
listen let's help you Suzuki get out
there and announce it and then see if
the support there and sure enough I
think we're over 2.5 million dollars I'm
funded for the project and of course
we're supporting it as well so we're
gonna we're gonna put our horsepower
behind it as well to make sure that it's
a fantastic experience and a great game
and so being able to be a part of that
to help him fulfill his dream he was
very emotional rightly so about it and
the fans hopefully are excited about -
and I backed it right after as soon as I
was in my car afterwards I was like and
kick star wars back up so when you say
Sony supporting it are you able to share
details on how yeah I mean obviously
we're we're providing some some funny as
well but we never disclosed for the
business side of things and then from
marketing perspective of course we're
gonna get behind in a big way so it's an
important part of of you know I think
video game heritage and history and so
we want to make sure we support it and
elevate as much as we can and two of the
other I think really big Sony gets is
continuing that destiny PlayStation 4 is
the first place to get that you also got
call of duty we got wow that was a big
get yeah what went into - acquiring the
rights to be the first platform for
those for the content for both is well I
think the first thing was obviously you
know we've had a great relationship with
Activision run around destiny and I'm a
huge fan of that and then they invited
us down you know to see to see the game
see black ops 3 and we fell in love with
instantly like as soon as I started
playing I'm like this feels incredible
like the wall right it just it's so
smooth it's almost like poetic and so
obviously we just continue talking with
our partners at Activision and Worksop
now and now we've got I think a great a
great benefit to all the gamers getting
that you know the first playable beta
which is a big deal and they get to the
mat PACs first for a PlayStation fans so
I'm a huge fan I think this one is
transformative I mean and in mark Lamia
up there on stage last night it was
awesome to see his his passion and
Vaughn's passion to the multiplayer just
plays so I mean it's one of the things
that if we go down there and we have to
play it - and if we love it and enjoy it
which we totally did then that's when we
were like okay this is something
want to get behind so you guys had a had
a ton of games on the show floor and it
was just like basically back to that
game yeah but there were a couple games
we didn't hear about do you think those
are things we're gonna grow out Gamescom
is there anything you can tease that's
it's gonna be coming up that fans can
look forward to well it's so funny it's
always the first question I get at the
end of every press conference what about
this game what about back here there's
so week we've talked if you'd like to
look at the last couple of years like it
look at Gamescom shows of the past and
e3 is the past and place user experience
last year there's so many games we
talked about and we just want to make
sure that when we showing the new
updates to the games that there's
something meaningful to show and so
we're always gonna be all this stuff
that we've announced the past of course
you know unless unless something gets
cancelled which we always tell people
that it gets canceled those things are
still developing so you're gonna see
more updates
of course shoes teams on Rob worldwide
studios are working hard on their stuff
you know like the witness we showed at
our PlayStation 4 launch event and
Jonathan Blow news team is still working
on that and when we do have builds like
no man's sky last night we try to show
that stuff off but a lot more stuff
coming we got a lot of shows coming up
too so we're gonna continue to fill them
chock-a-block and reduce the bad dad
jokes that I tell on stage and just show
the many games off as possible are we
gonna be hearing more about project
Morpheus soon yeah I mean the show for
right now we have a ton of stuff on the
stage you know one of the challenges
with VR in general is just like showing
it off on a stage is always so difficult
so I think touching on it and then
having people experience this is really
what the goal is so we have more demo
units here than we've ever had before we
have more games than we've ever had so
that we're showing on it we've got a lot
of third-party content that's showing
out for it so there's a lot of great
stuff and of course it's gonna be
something as we drive towards launch
will be talking lots more about it but
to us it's also about getting people
getting their heads in in the set
because that's when you really
understand we are and so that's I think
a big focus of of us as a company so
we're sitting here upstairs but
downstairs III is literally opening up
yeah right now so it it's away I've done
a chance to try out stuff did you check
out Microsoft and Nintendo's press
conference do you have any thoughts on I
did no no I do I do I'm just a huge
gamer nerd I like I love videogames and
I got a lot of friends of mine in the
industry that I worked for all those all
those other companies and it's very I
thought they're both solid solid
conferences I thought the publisher
conferences agree I was at Bethesda's I
mean doom looked amazing 12 cores
incredible EA stuff having Paley
there was really neat we saw I mean
there's so much great content out there
that it says often time for dangerous
cuz now I feel like we're in this it's
it's I was actually talking on Michael
Gallagher who runs the ESA and it just
it feels like we're back in a really
really big way right because VR is here
that's a big story the AR stuff and
mixed reality stuffs really neat and
then video games in general they're just
we have any games that can look
incredible like no man scars is so epic
and then we also have the big each
replace stuff that's also sort of
feeding us and keeping us I mean 200
hours of the desk good enough so yeah I
think there's a lot of great stuff and I
think the other guys are very great job
dude yeah before the consoles launched
there was a lot of talk about maybe this
is the last console generation but
that's obviously not true PlayStation
it's the fastest I mean it's the fastest
one calls on the history of the world I
mean that's that's crazy to me
even saying that phrase sounds weird but
it's true and I don't think any of us
really hopes and cut across your fingers
but the fact that it's work around sway
is great and it means that there's more
opportunities for people to make great
games and so our focus is like how do we
keep getting a great breadth of content
out there and getting people to try new
in different things well awesome thanks
so much for attending
absolutely and I look forward to
checking out some of the Sony games on
the show floor later today
you